as-salam-o-alaikum looking for my
brother mohammed here he goes right here
how do we leave off last time I saw one
[Music]
of the unique things when you're in the
UK is is where you actually where people
are the right huh oh yeah we want to get
our books in our hands right we also
here in the UK they drive on the right
yes right pretty cool have you ever
driven on the left yeah yeah I have
found it quite difficult yeah it's easy
to adjust the only thing you gotta think
about is when you when you turn it right
and when you're turning left is
different so obviously when you're
turning left here it's it's a short left
yeah long right but in America it's the
opposite so it's a long left and a short
right uh-huh
because obviously they drive on the side
of the road that's the main thing to
think about
tell me what you think yesterday when I
was out and this is for the people to
see like you know different forms of
sparking people's interest I kept
hearing this word cheers Cheers
we don't hear that much yeah so then we
I asked somebody I said hey what's more
appropriate cheers or thank you I said
excuse me sir can you tell me what's
preferable I'm trying to you know get to
know some of these words cheers or
thanks and he was leaning more towards
tears and explaining what it was
I think cheese is more friendly uh-huh
like you like talking to one of your
mates yeah and I said well after he
explained I said well we say I said I'm
old ankle okay you guys get into cheers
thank you listen how's that
all right good thank you Cheers we say
Salaam alaikum yeah I heard that one
yeah yeah peace be with you
thank you so I left them with that just
that by itself because we're crossing
the street there's not much time to
engage yeah and obviously I mean how
many times do you have a Muslim come up
to you and just you know meet you like
that and and and have this unique
situation happened another person was
they were standing in front of the the
Prime Minister's place yeah down is it
down yes so I I engaged with one person
and I and I and I told him the judaculla
doozy yeah I recorded this so your
thoughts you know just to showing people
that sometimes you know you have
obviously going over the belief system
and everything explained at OU he'd the
one is then sometimes you know it's like
an art like sometimes you just don't
have that opportunity to know you know
give someone so you want to leave them
with something so I told the guy I'm a
tourist not a terrorist
I'm visiting I'm a tourist not at areas
but I'm listening
yeah I'm ready nice to meet you America
what's your name I'm Eunice
where're you from Swedish nice to meet
you thank you thank you this is I have a
TV show called the diva show like yeah
I'm gonna give you my card you can check
it out you ever met a Muslim yeah yeah
or or just on the news yeah well you got
a new friend
I can check me out sure okay buddy thank
you Pastor move you ever met a Muslim
yeah gave my card and we went off and
and it was nice it's cuz you know you
can think like at one point is something
it's something very far school it's out
there why would you say something like
that
but it is it it's this whole concept of
Muslims being terrorists and people
fearing it's so stupid and ridiculous
that sometimes he requires something
established so if you want to live in
London you have to you're gonna come
into contact with Muslims as a matter of
fact and in Birmingham which is the
second biggest see in UK it's it's
becoming very very much densely
populated or Muslim so in these big
cities they've definitely come across
Muslims and it's laughing they need to
get used to it it's so they're probably
going used to already but when I went to
Chicago is a big difference because the
communities are not as I think you'll be
surprised especially you go to East
London it's probably more likely you ask
about are you Muslim that they say yes
and no it's a lot Muslims here
but something's come up for us to be
alone yeah usually that's the thing you
have so many places like in the US I
guess that in different parts of the
world what we're make that human
connection where people who haven't made
that connection right they think all
sorts of crazy things they've been
watching the media and they have all
sorts of ideas in their head yeah but
you know what what is your what do you
like to do when you don't have much time
but you have an opportune time possibly
to leave someone with something to think
about what kind of seed do you like the
plan you know it's a very good question
and in cells they call it like the
elevator pitch because you only have a
certain amount of time say for example
you an elevator you only have a certain
amount of time to try and sell your
product whatever is your trying to do so
just get them to think about purpose of
life I think that's one of the key
things ask them what's the purpose of
life you know what are we doing here you
know and so on and these things I think
are quite powerful if you leave someone
with say okay where did we come from why
are we here and where are we going you
don't need to even mention god but it
should be a straightforward inference
for them so they might think okay well
where did we come from and then you can
start having discussion of creation why
am I here and where am I going after
life and so on so you can say it without
saying it basically that's deep getting
people to reflect purpose of life
everything around you have a purpose
what about you the human being so lonely